this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by liquid iv
raycon and stitch fix more on that later
let's get into the do
the honeydew with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i'm ryan sickler
ryan sickler on all social media ryan
sickler.com
make sure you're subscribed to the
youtube channel we got audio on mondays
video on tuesdays don't just watch hit
that subscribe
um and if you gotta have more episodes
man hit the patreon up the honeydew with
you all
if you or anyone out there you know has
that story that has to be heard
submit it at honeydewpodcast gmail.com
we'll vet em we'll get to them the
community is growing we've heard
i mean i don't know if y'all out there
watching but we just had a story about a
guy
getting someone else's face blown off
onto his face
this [ __ ] is cr you all have not let me
down it's getting crazier and crazier
absolutely love it um get your night
pants get your merch all that good stuff
you know i record here at the santa
monica music center every week
uh if you need musical instruments or
lessons for your kids this is the spot
you can get online classes
uh go to santa monicamusic.com use the
code honeydew they'll weigh the
registration fee and they'll give you
one free lesson when you sign up for a
package all right that's the biz
that's all right and i appreciate you
trying
to try it out that's right it's like
the cope with lungs well what we do here
is we highlight the low lights as i
always say these are the stories behind
the storytellers and
i i do want to say this thank you for
all the messages
all the dms everything you guys send
about how this is changing your lives
how you started going to therapy all
that stuff
um but uh this guest here today first
time here on the honeydew very excited
to have him here
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
brendan shaw y'all
brendan schaab on the honeydew
thank you for being here i just squealed
like i was 17 bro i got excited hell
yeah
um thank you you look good in pink by
the way oh thanks i think about wearing
it all the time
it's pink yeah you gotta be comfortable
in your own skin to rock paint
um before we get into what we're going
to talk about today please plug
everything when when's this drop in just
like two weeks you know about seven
weeks
do you know where you're at seven weeks
it's gonna be i don't know where i'm
gonna be next week
what do you got going on yeah i
literally don't know you know just
firing the kids
uh king of the sting and then blow the
belt podcast and i'm on the road i'm all
over
you're doing your showtime show too
showtime food truck diaries i love that
show yeah i saw jesus on it
yeah yeah yeah yeah things are good man
um
busy which is good it is good there's
also nothing worse when you ask someone
hey how's it going busy
how are you oh are you busy you know is
there a worse answer
busy business okay you just want to make
sure everybody knows
you're working i just i've always been a
good guy i've always i'm good
even when [ __ ] is horrible even when
it's horrible i'm good
when it's good i'm good if i'm doing if
things are real bad you're
hanging in there man
how you doing everything hanging in
there
all right so there's a few things i want
to talk to you about we talked a little
bit about football mma but first let's
talk about where you're from you grew up
in denver denver
born and raised and and was your dad an
athlete was your mom an athlete like
what got you into where do you get your
jeans from
yeah um i probably my dad's side like my
dad's like
six three two twenty like in better
shape than i am like shredded
for real right now right now 65 damn
beast he stays in shape stays in shape
works out every day
was he an athlete back in the day yeah
he played football
and then he was in the navy i come from
a military family
my thing is kind of a weird story
because where i grew up really i'm from
aurora colorado
and aurora colorado now is a little
different but when i grew up it was like
it was definitely like a more urban area
like all my friends were black i grew up
around uh
black people my best friends were black
so the the best way to kind of
fit in and like make a name for yourself
or get girls was to be good at sports
so i was gifted with athletic genes but
i never had like that
athletic mentality you know i don't have
that kobe mentality that manny pacquiao
mentality
it was just like all right well i guess
i'm gifted in this i'll do this
but you know i my heroes were like adam
sandler jim carrey
but there was no avenue for that and i
you know for where i got in life in
sports i was really good at sports
so it's like all right i guess you're
good at this this is what you do man
and when did you realize very young high
school
oh wait before that way before that that
you could be that you're better than
everybody like what's
what's your earliest memory of just dust
and everybody was it football was it
private uh we had the virginia court
elementary
in i was in third grade and i was just
like i'm gonna make money doing this
you know it's like um i'm way better
than everybody yeah but it wasn't a pop
warner
it was yeah it wasn't a cocky thing i
remember my coach
um again because i never like it wasn't
a passion i was just good at it and i
was getting like a lot of
positive like comments all the time so
that's good and
that released those endorphins and i
knew i could you know make a name for
myself
in sports but um yeah i was i was in
third grade and i didn't want to play
anymore but my dad bought all the
equipment
and it was like halfway through the
season i was like i don't want to play
that i want to go hang out with my
friend and like do this stuff and
he's like all right well if you quit
you're just not going to quit you got to
go talk to the team and tell them
so he marched me up there got me in
front of third grade
in third grade marched me in front of
everyone and the coaches russ brown shot
to russ brown still talked to him to
this do you really yeah yeah so
he comes to all my shows does he his son
dakota start fighting
yeah it's great so uh you know he
gathered the team and
my dad's like go tell them all the [ __ ]
you're telling me go tell tell the team
look them in their eyes tell me you're
giving up and i'll
everybody i just started crying and then
the coach rushed brown they're crying
through the best kids
yeah my coaching side was like yeah
yeah the head coach took me to the side
of the caveman you're really important
to the team like you're the
team you're the quarterback yeah you're
the running back you're the same he's
like your
kick returner you're our entire playbook
you're our entire playbook if you leave
i'm gonna lose my job
yes so yeah he's just like you're really
important the team
it'd be really you know disappointing if
you left so i stuck with it
uh but that was like a learning time but
i i knew i was gifted in athletics at a
young age
what i mean what did that do for you
moving forward did it instill in you
that you
that team and you don't quit yes yeah it
really did
flash back on that oh yeah even
i think about you know because i have
two young sons now and i think about
just some of the stuff my dad did i'm
like god what a beast man
like he never let us get away with
anything work ethic was everything he
worked his ass off
so you know at a young age i was like oh
this is how
this is how you act so just that my work
ethic which
comics or you know other athletes talk
about this work ethic
that's my dad man that's good isn't it
interesting too when you sit and listen
to somebody they're like i've been
they say busy like you say like oh yeah
and then they tell you what they've been
up to and you're like
like bubba that's my monday yeah that's
what you know that's that's when i
started learning out here the difference
between what people think hard work is
even in life not just out here
especially if you think that's hard
i know but especially if you're around
comics you know
like i i think uh where i got my success
in comedy is just the difference of work
ethic compared to a lot of guys like
the the work ethic economy really
separates the pack
is there funny or guys i mean oh hands
down easy but as far as work ethic it'd
be tough to find someone who outworks me
that's right and i take pride in that
what um okay so
when so that's football and that's
football but also
you know again so i go from pop one or i
was a star there
and i get into high school i was getting
high school and but i was never
all state or anything like that in high
school yeah i was uh i was
so this is where it gets dicey yeah i
was all conference but
um i played lacrosse two and i was all
stupid wow
you were playing in colorado yep all
state uh you know captain the team
but my senior year our first game of the
season
you know that's back then too that's
when you're getting recruited and i you
know i was
want to go play at some pretty big
schools and we played at uh
disney disney world we flew down there
to play this other team cypress creek i
think this big team
and their star quarterback had a full
ride to florida state
and i was getting recruited by like
texas a m cal all these schools
and so the first play um we knew going
into the game
my coach tony manfredi was like hey
we're gonna we're gonna
first play we're gonna hit him in the
mouth we're gonna throw you a deep ball
and just let him know what's up like
hell yeah watch this
florida state check this out they throw
the ball
this florida state savage
intercepts the ball with one arm
she's like douche not today white boy
takes off down the field i'm like what
the [ __ ] is that leon sanders
he takes off with the ball oh first play
the game i'm chasing him down like all
right he got he
he got the interception but i'm gonna
strip him get the ball back and that
that'd be on film i'm thinking in my
head i'm like this is gonna look dope
and i
fly up to him i go to strip the ball and
he
jukes the biggest guy in our team gary
moore who is six
eight 375 pounds and gary you know he
gets
juked and he doesn't always do when gary
gets juked and just like
dies and runs full speed into my ribs
shatters my ribs for real
oh shatters my wrist my ribs run into my
liver and have a lacerated liver
so i missed the entire season playing
one place oh [ __ ]
played one play one play one play
so that was like a wake-up call [ __ ] and
then no
you know they didn't know if i was gonna
be able to play so i mean what kind of
what do they have to do to repair you
from that
there's nothing you do like lacerated
liver you know i was in the hospital
i know ribs there's nothing but you
can't do anything they don't have to cut
you open now because it wasn't
it was deep enough so it was just like a
you know surface last
river so i couldn't fly back so i was
freaking stuck in disney world for like
four weeks
a month and then the doctor would come
in like
he's never going to play again i'm like
now i think back i'm like what a dick
dude
yeah man like i don't need this news i
say it all the time you know what they
called a guy to finish last in med
school
doctor yeah you're right so he was like
he's never going to play again so i'm
crying stuff like that
so then my rat was was just different i
was no longer this big recruit
i lost you know all interest in scouting
so then i went to a small school at
whittier in california where i could
play lacrosse in football
played a year there i was freshman of
the year in both sports and then
transferred to university of colorado so
i
found my way back i had to walk onto the
team at unc college oh you were a walk
on there
i was a walk-on for a year and a half
and then got my scholarship
damn all right and what position did you
play when you walked on
i was tied in and then went very cool we
have a tight end here who
eventually became my best friend and we
played pop warner together like we have
a tight end here he's gonna be a first
round draft pick his name's joe
kloffenstein
so you're gonna play fullback oh that
makes sense
yeah i'll do that so you know i was a
fullback just getting ct left and right
and uh it was a good experience though
you know and how
how do you start getting looks from the
nfl when's the first time you hear that
well let me go let me go back for yeah
do you think at the time
you say you don't have the mama
mentality or whatever but do you think
at the time in college
hey i could i could play in the nfl yeah
because
i was around like when i was a sophomore
even when i was a you know
a redshirt freshman i was around guys
who were getting drafted and i could see
how i
compared to them i was like oh yeah i
might be better than this guy got
dropped in the third round i might be
bringing this guy in the fourth round
so i knew that i could i could get to
that level
and when do you start getting interest
when you start hearing anything
my senior year there's some rumblings
but then it was it was
it was tough man because my experience
in college was
was really tough because since i was
like an h-back fullback
i was in the running back room and i was
the only white guy my coach was black
and it was weird because it was like
almost reverse
racism in there because if let's say
we're playing nebraska or we're playing
another team they had a white running
back
they spent a half an hour making fun of
that team for having a white running
back
and my coach was like everybody knows
white boys can't play like black players
yeah he'd be like i would never play a
white guy
he's sitting right there and so i you
know i was really good and everyone's
like dude why aren't you playing anymore
i was like
[ __ ] fair con over there's not gonna
you know what i'm saying like
he's not gonna let me play man so our
offense coordinator shout out to uh sean
watson
he you know we had a the the big
scrimmage where
they decide who you know where you gonna
be on the depth chart and the starter
was out with like a rolled ankle
so i played the whole game and i scored
the highest out of the game
and the i was in the weight room the
next day working out then our
offense grenade watson came up and was
just like
you're you're my favorite guy in the
team you do everything we ask is he
white or black
he's white oh he's like yeah of course
he's like you do everything we ask
and he's like if things were different
you'd be a starter he's like but they're
not and you know you know it doesn't
work like that i'm like
and that he told me yeah i know i know
i'm right
and that's like the first i was like oh
this is a business and
you know because i was a walk-on and the
way for your viewers i don't know how
the way sports work especially division
one
so coaches recruit all season they have
their guys that they give full rides to
and those are their guys and give them
every opportunity as a walk-on you come
out of nowhere
you bust your ass but you're no one's
guy so you have to be
undeniable like just a freak talent to
get playing time
that's one thing i love about the ravens
it's been like 13 seasons in a row
they've
they've taken an undrafted guy yeah they
get like the token white
slot there's usually a guy that comes in
but no they usually do well like
they're guys that don't get drafted and
then they come to the ravens and we
breed linebackers
like the way the ra the broncos used to
have running backs
and these guys come in and then usually
they leave the ravens and they don't
excel because we use them the way they
probably should be played but yeah it's
a shame i you know that
that's when you know your eyes open up
to like oh this is a business right
and then you know because i was so
dialed in with football
you know when i was a kid i knew i had
the skills make the nfl so
nfl was my willy wonkas chocolate
factory i was like if i can just get an
opportunity i'm gonna
i'm gonna flourish so i thought maybe i
get drafted late don't get drafted go to
my buddy joe klobenstein
uh his draft party he gets drafted
they're all celebrating i'm crying
crying i was like oh man so
uh and dude
and i'm just i'm texting with my agent
tom mill shout out tom mills i haven't
said that name forever
i'm texting him like hey man any uh any
news i'm hoping i could like
at least let my family and my friends
know who are here at this other kid's
draft party like
i have something going on following me
and so he's like oh
uh buffalo's interested i'm like okay
probably the last place i want to go
but let's do it so uh you know i come
out i'm like
looks like i'm had to buffalo everybody
but i knew the business where
white guy undrafted free agent like it's
a long shot
and the day i'm leaving that morning i
told my dad i'm like dad
the chance of me making this team is not
good man so don't get your hopes up like
you know and he's all excited he's like
yeah i'm not going too man don't worry
so i get out to buffalo uh that's gotta
be a pretty cool thing for your dad
though my son's
i don't know yeah i don't know he's
never really talked about it i don't
know he never missed a game ever when it
college pop warner
college you know we played all at the
time big 12. so all over texas
oklahoma played in bowl games against
clemson played at miami
he's uh a computer uh data guy
now doesn't it amaze you that he made
every one of those [ __ ]
every single game every game on the road
sold my brother everything
they never missed anything how the [ __ ]
he did that me neither
amazing crazy so i told him like don't
get your hopes up dad like this is a
long [ __ ] shot i'm vince papali and this
[ __ ] like you know like it's
gonna be a
beast for me to make it he's like yeah
no doubt so i fly out there
and i think that how'd they hear about
you what was who was i did pro day
so i did that's like the combine at the
low at your college and i i did really
well and they had a scout i had a scout
there yeah
so that guy's like all right let's give
this kid a chance so i go out there
they have me run a 40 having me do all
this stuff and i'm in training camp
and i knew i was in trouble because i
didn't get any reps i got one rep
the quarterback like threw the ball way
over my head and i was like well that's
not good my one rep this [ __ ]
like way to go dude with a one time and
then i saw
another player with my jersey who's
number 43 i'm like well
yeah there's not two for like it's not
college like there's only one
jersey of 43 and he was like a first
round draft pick from like miami i was
like oh this isn't good
so i was there maybe three days her hurt
my uh
hamstring got cut flew back home from
buffalo
from buffalo fly all the way from
[ __ ] buffalo orchard park back to
denver colorado
and i'm like so upset because you get to
you realize how hot dogs are made and
it's so
hard it's such a business it's such a
savage business
it just breaks your heart because as a
kid you don't you don't think about
those things
so i get back to denver and outside my
outside of my dad's house he has a
buffalo bill's flag
[Laughter]
you can believe this i got jim kelly
coming at 15
[Laughter]
hopefully you're a steve tasker fan
because i don't play for the buffalo
bills man
you hadn't told him or anything no just
showed up
and he was like he was so oh dude he was
so broken out of buffalo bills coffee
mug and [ __ ]
what are you doing here four days later
what are you doing here
what am i doing here not i'm not playing
football am i i'm not playing for this
team
yeah i'm so then i go through like i
rehab my
hamstring i'm like i gotta move on
i gotta move on and then the utah blaze
arena league team called me like we'd
love to have you man man like yo
that's something else i actually went
and watched um the la team
and i'm look i'm a ravens fan so i am a
fan of defense there's no
it was this [ __ ] sprinting from
20 yards back they get to the line of
scrimmage
and it's just bombs i swear to god it
was like 75 to 68 or some [ __ ] like that
well even
even that was heartbreaking because uh
like i'm trying to get on team
i'm living with my brother at time i'm
hustling i'm selling supplements i'm
like trying to find make ends meet
and this is where again denver denver
and so i moved in with my brother i
didn't have any money
and um you know i i went out
saw utah blaze i tried out for them and
then you know where i'm waiting for a
call to see if i made the team i come
back hungry dad's got a blaze
like where did you even find that i made
that team though
i made that too so i make that team i
call my brothers first person i call you
hey your your little brother's a
professional athlete
and uh he's like oh it's cool i called
my dad and he's like oh that's so cool
so they drive with me out to salt lake
city to drop me off at the hotel with
where we're all staying
and i meet with the coach and he's like
yeah so what he goes it's just
heartbreaking dude he goes so what we're
thinking
is do you think you can get to 300
pounds how much were you i'm sorry what
i was like 250.
oh he's like do you think you can get to
300 pounds like
probably not he's like we'd really
appreciate if you get to 300 i'm like
this isn't for me man so i didn't say
anything at a time like i have nothing
else to do
so i go through listen it would i don't
care if you're under the
the guidance of a professional it would
take considerable amount of time to gain
50 [ __ ] pounds i don't know what they
were thinking
i don't know 50. even if you just ate
mcdonald's all day long
it would take you a minute to get the
50. yeah they wanted me to get the three
hundo so i was like i don't definitely
want to do this so i go through camp
with them
halfway through kevin like i'm talking
to a guy he's like yeah i also work at
ups
and i'm like oh oh you what he said yeah
we're at ups i'm like
full time yeah yeah i'm like shout out
to ups yeah i'm like
primary one joe avenue dude and the guy
he's like yeah i work at re max like
this you're the star coordinator remax
he's wait how much are we making
you know it's like oh oh work i guess
i guess we're professionals oh god so
yeah yeah i was like god this isn't for
me so i
i start a quarterback working here
got my car and drove home you can't
that's your route it's like i quit
your dad's like take the flag back yeah
all right get take it get get the flag
done
so yeah i stopped doing that and then uh
yeah i was just heartbreaking you never
tried canadian or any of that no
i was like oh no if i can't play if i
can't play in the nfl i don't want to do
this
and it's just heartbreaking man super
heartbreaking heart heartbreaking
so then i go back home living with my
brother again selling supplements door
to door
and um i always had a knack for like jiu
jitsu i love jiu-jitsu all right so
let's
hold on there and dial back for a second
that's what i wanted to ask you during
football and all this
when are you taking jiu jitsu also like
yeah i took jiu jitsu in the off seasons
in boulder
like high school or earlier no college
oh that lately
yeah i didn't start to college okay and
even then it was like my senior year i'd
take some classes
again because my best friend joe
clothenstein was in the uh like
pride mixed martial arts fighting stuff
like that so you discovered that
late late yeah and again i was really
good at it
and then uh again really good to all
perspective
but i had a knack for it um
so then you know i just i just signed up
at a local like gym
and uh still in denver all in denver
still training not making any money
and then uh i take a class and then the
the instructor goes hey you should come
tomorrow because there's another big guy
who's just getting started you should
come tomorrow because
you're too big for everybody man like
everybody's small you're not gonna get
much work out of it
but this guy comes every thursday from
greeley he drives from greeley which is
like two and a half hour drive
because he comes every thursday so he he
he doesn't have anybody trained with so
come back tomorrow so i come back
tomorrow like who is this guy and this
guy at the time was a nobody like me his
name was shane carwin
who became the ufc heavyweight champion
of the world and he was like a big
brother to me
so he was older than me he took me under
his wing me and him were just training
he had like
and he's driving all that way because he
doesn't have anyone his size to spar
with is that he's driving because the
the
the school high altitude martial arts
and aurora was started by nate marquart
who was a ufc famous ufc fighter the
only ufc fighter at the time like with
well-known
so that was like where you went because
he was the one guy who made it
got it so everyone that was the spot so
and that's how i found it
so you know me and him just started
training together he only had one fight
i'd corner him
and then uh he was like hey man uh
next week's uh golden gloves boxing i go
all right cool i'm not a boxer he goes
yeah i signed you up for it
what i don't want to [ __ ] how long
have you been even
six months that's it yeah he's like
you're in golden gloves he's like so get
your mind right and he's about to go
against somebody that could have been
training since they were eight
dude so he signed up for golden gloves
oh my god i don't wanna i felt so much
pressure to do it like all right you
paid for it he's like yeah man
sent in all your [ __ ] like you're you're
[ __ ] fighting dude
so my guy i sell supplements so i i go
to golden gloves my dad comes my dad's
like what are you doing i was like dad
listen
if if i don't win this whole thing which
i was underdogs if i don't win this
whole thing i'll stop doing all this
[ __ ]
but just come to support me you know my
dad he's like all right i'll come
so my dad comes and the way golden
gloves works is
especially at the time it's like me and
all mixing kids
so uh the first i have like three fights
the first night you fight back to back
i all knockouts i get three knockouts in
a round like wow
i'm like that's weird wait first time
okay so the first time you knock a guy
out
all right have you ever knocked someone
out before and just a fist fighter
never been in a street fight no no
really no
just your brothers messing around just
my my older brother beat the [ __ ] on me
but i'm like
one and nine thousand against him i won
one fight when i was like
seven so this is the first time you've
ever knocked real fast
how'd you do it where did you catch him
with a right hook he just came in i hit
him and they went down like oh really
and then i felt bad i was going man
i was like are you all right dude he's
like can you get the [ __ ] out of here's
mexican families front row
so now three knockouts which is kind of
unheard of in golden gloves which was
news to me
i'm like i thought boxing we knock each
other out and they're like no dumbass
this is like
amateur boxing no one really gets
knocked out you have the headgear and
stuff too
yeah you still knock them out damn
so the next night i'm in the
championship and my dad's like
yeah man what is happening it's like in
a rough area and it's like what are you
doing dude i'm like i don't know
and you're getting your hands wrapped in
the crowd because there's no like green
room that you're just getting it's
[ __ ] you know so i'm getting my hands
wrapped
and my dad goes who are you fighting in
the championship my god the guy's name's
like an adam or something
and this giant black guy comes walking
by my dad goes
jesus christ i know and i go oh my god
and he goes what's up man i'm adam and
he goes to fist-bump me and he's like
a man yeah he's he's a man he's like a
man
he's a man and so uh my coach goes
yeah you know it's probably better you
know what you sign up for he goes he was
the army
champ he's like 41 and now man i didn't
sign up for this [ __ ]
yeah i don't want to be here so he's
like yeah he was the military army champ
he's like 41-0 i'm like
what he's under i'm like how the [ __ ]
what are we doing here
he's like just give it your best shot
knock him out in the second round
no win golden gloves so i went golden
you knocked him out knocked him out
dude yeah so yeah i'm laughing because
i'm thinking of the announcer being like
3-0
and he's 41-0 like two undefeated they
don't even know you
knocked that [ __ ] out knocked
him out yeah i got it so now you're 4-0
with four knockouts four knockouts
yeah and then it was off to the races
then then i took my dad going nuts
no no no he was like you're a [ __ ] you
have you know i was a double major
business sociology he's like you got me
was he going nuts from the knockouts
but he was still like dude like come on
you don't like kids like you don't fight
man like the
there's much tougher guys yeah he's like
there's a million things you could do
he's like use your business mind and
start a business do something and uh
i was like well let's see what happens
with this so and how old are you
at this point now fresh out fresh out of
college so what 24
four 20 22 23 so
um yeah so one golden gloves and then
shane carr when he was fighting mma at
the time i was cornering him
so he's like oh you know let's get you
on this card so he gets me my first mma
fight
and where is that that's in broomfield
colorado okay
and you'll see there's a common theme
because i get thrown just to the big
leagues right
in comedy football fighting i get the
big leagues right away where
i probably shouldn't be there so in mma
i get put on
it's called ring of fire which is the
big big promotion out there like the
biggest
it's their version of the ufc it's at
broomfield event center you know which
is a big deal
and uh it's my first mma fight and i
knocked him out in like
34 seconds the [ __ ] out here when my mom
comes
my mom comes and i see her after and uh
my mom's born raised in england like
she's a rough you know funny lady but
like rough and she's like
cool so uh when are you back on i'm like
what she goes when are you back on i go
well mom that that's the fight there's
only one i knocked him out in 30 seconds
like this is a good thing she goes
i drove all the way to [ __ ] she goes
i drove all the way to [ __ ]
broomfield
for 30 seconds i go this is a good thing
she goes get the [ __ ] out of it
never came to fight against never came
to fight again never
never that's hilarious
my mom's funny man let's take a quick
break and tell you about our first
sponsor
liquid iv i think we can all agree 2020
was rough it's time to clean the slate
and start 2021 off on the right foot one
goal i have for myself this year is to
stay healthy
and i'll be doing that with the help of
my favorite hydration product
liquid iv with one stick of liquid iv in
16 ounces of water you get two to three
times the amount of hydration
as plain water liquid iv has incredible
hydration flavors
like watermelon lemon lime and passion
fruit and they recently launched
strawberry imagine
a freshly picked taste of ripe juicy
strawberries topped with decadent notes
of whipped cream amazing now look i've
told you guys
throughout my covet i took liquid iv
absolutely took
the tangerine that has zinc
vitamin d all the things they say are
essential and it kept me hydrated
it kept me healthy i was lucky to not
have
some severe side effects and i
absolutely use liquid iv
the entire time now liquid iv contains
five essential vitamins
more vitamin c than an orange and as
much potassium as a banana it's
healthier than the sugary sports drinks
there are no artificial flavors or
preservatives and there's less sugar
than an
apple it's made with clean ingredients
it's non-gmo
vegan and free of gluten dairy and soy
one stick of liquid iv in 16 ounces of
water can give as much
hydration as two to three bottles of
plain water the company is donating 4
million servings in response to coven
19.
products are being donated to hospitals
first responders food banks
veterans and active military grab your
strawberry liquid iv or their other
great flavors in bulk nationwide at
costco
or you can get 25 off when you go to
liquidive.com
and use the code honeydew at checkout
that's 25
off of anything you order when you use
the promo code honeydew at liquidive.com
get better hydration today at liquid
iv.com
our next sponsor is raycon you know how
much i love my raycons
i finally got a new pair for myself and
i'm enjoying them i love them
uh and i don't know about you but i feel
like i'm always looking at my screen
these days now more than ever
and whether you're an avid news watcher
or you're in serious need of distraction
unplugging yourself is easier said than
done
one of my favorite ways to rest my eyes
and still get the content i'm itching
for
is by putting in my raycom wireless
earbuds and listening to something great
like the honeydew podcast
and the honeydew with you all on my
patreon whether you're catching up on
your favorite news podcast
binging an audiobook or powering through
your workout with a pumped up playlist
a pair of raicons in your ears can make
all the difference there's no dangling
wires or stems to get in your way here
all right raycons come in a range of
stylish colorways
but always with a comfortable in-ear fit
for a more discreet look
raycons are built to perform anywhere
and anytime with water and sweat
resistant construction and bluetooth
that pairs quickly and seamlessly and
with enough battery life for six hours
of playtime
you can unplug for a while and the best
part is raycom makes great sound
accessible to everyone
with wireless earbuds starting at half
the price
of other premium audio brands all right
so raycon is offering 15
of all their products for my listeners
here's what you got to do to get it you
go to buy raycon dot com slash honeydew
that's it you get 15 off your entire
raycon order
so feel free to grab a pair and a spare
that's 15 percent off
at buyraicon.com honeydew
by raycon.com honeydew
hear the difference our next sponsor is
stitch fix so
if your go-to outfit in 2020s becomes
sweatshirts
or yoga pants you may be feeling like
you're in a style rut
all right but let stitch fix help you
feel excited about what you're wearing
stitch fix
offers clothing hand selected by expert
stylist
for your unique size style and budget
every piece is chosen for your fit
and your life and it's the easy solution
to finding what makes you look and feel
your best
try on pieces at home before you buy
them you can keep your favorites
send back the rest stitch fix has free
shipping easy returns and exchanges and
a prepaid return
envelope is included there's no
subscription required
you just try stitch fix once or you can
set up automatic deliveries
you'll pay just a twenty dollar styling
fee for each box
which gets credited toward the pieces
you keep and there are no hidden fees
ever okay stitch fix has styles and
clothing to fit any occasion for women
men they even have kids they ship all
over the us
and they're available in the uk as well
i'm using them right now man it's so
easy you go on
you pick the stores you like to shop
from and look they've got everything
from under armour nike
polo you name it so get started today
go to stitchfix.com honeydew
and you'll get 25 off when you keep
everything in your fix
that's stitchfix.com honeydew for 25
off when you keep everything in your fix
stitchfix.com
honeydew now let's get back to the do
all right so you're 4-0
four foreign i knocked that guy out i
clicked he was
uh i clipped him he falls down and she
got on top
pound them out and then uh i have three
more fights in that same organization
knock all those guys out and like i
think my longest fight was like 50
seconds
so there's like some buzz around me but
even i'm like this is insane this is so
stupid but knowing what
you know and i know about wrestling
fighting you've never been tested
you haven't been passed a minute i've
been tested in the gym because remember
my
training partner shane carmen who
eventually became the ufc world champion
but you're
[ __ ] good and again i know how i
stand up next to him
i mean you haven't had to go six minutes
but that's
kind of but as a prospect that's kind of
how it should be yeah you should be
starching dudes if you're gonna make it
to them you're right about that you
should be starching these [ __ ] bums
at your face that's what they all said
about tyson too he hadn't been here he's
never been tested into a fight
so i'm like 4-0 3-0 in mixed martial
arts
just fought bums and then uh i get a
call from the ultimate fighter
which was at the time a big big deal it
was the reality show where they took 16
fighters put them in the house
and i they bring me for interviews and
you know i've never met a camera i don't
like so when i'm
in front of the camera you know i put on
a show
and i walk out and then like you got the
gig without even like talking to agents
anything
as walking out like you're on the show
i'm like holy [ __ ] so i go on the
ultimate fighter
and that's with like guys who are
similar to my skill set all prospects
all
everybody's undefeated one guy in the
house was roy nelson who was
30 and he had like over 30 fights former
world champion had no business be in the
house but he's in the house with us
kimbo slice was on that season it's the
biggest season ever
so that was like the launching pad in my
career i make it to the finale
so in the house which is where how you
earn your contract if you go undefeated
in the house
you earn a ufc contract i go undefeated
i go 3-0
and i get to the finale and then i fight
roy nelson the finale the the experience
the guy that shouldn't be in that yeah
and get knocked out
that was my first loss yeah is that your
first time well it's your first loss
have you had you been knocked out ever
before in football or anything like that
so what was that like
do you remember seeing it what do you
remember of the knockout
i just remember being really embarrassed
and i couldn't believe it happened to me
and because i was kind of whooping his
ass and then i just remember
him just he hit me with one right hand i
was like that's it that was like the
first time i've been hitting a fight i'm
like that's it dude
and then he hit me behind the ear where
there's not much you can do about it
so and that knocked you out that yeah
put me out
and then i was just like heartbroken man
heartbroken and then uh
i remember an experienced fighter named
keith jardine who was a friend of mine
who's like a ufc hall of famer
came up to me and i'm like so sad nobody
can really tell you anything to get you
out of that
and he goes i'll tell you this man i've
had some losses he goes i feel sorry
forever
has to fight you next you say i feel so
sorry for that dude
i was like all right whatever dude three
months later the ufc gives me a contract
i earn my
you know my ticket to the chocolate
factory and then
i find a guy named chase gormley in
denver at broomfield event center
real quick what's a conch so wouldn't
they give you a contract
contract six fights guaranteed no no
no yeah nothing's guaranteed in fighting
so it's not like one felony
yeah so it's a six fight guarantee or a
six fight contract
but they can fire you at any time and
the way fighting works is
to show up and take the fight you get
this some if you win you get this some
so to get your whole paycheck you have
to win the fight okay
all right it's a bummer gotcha so you're
getting a flat fee but
i'm not balling but a bit it's a bit
it's like how much is it do you remember
yeah it's uh at the time of six and six
six grand to
take the fight six grand if you win so
12 grand
12 grand that's not a lot of money at
all especially after taxes and
everything
agents yeah 10 percent nightmare
nightmare
so yeah so my first fight in ufc i found
a guy in chase gormley in my hometown
i knocked him out in 47 seconds damn all
right does your record
of 4-1 carry into the ufc or you now re
start at zero and zero when you get
there
uh though it's for some weird reason
those fights i had on the ultimate
fighter which everybody saw which were
my biggest fights
they didn't count those okay so if i was
say 3-0 or 4-0 coming into the house i
won three fights i'd be 7-0
lost to roy seven and one then i i
should be seven and one when i fought
chase gormley
so in my head i've been seven eight
fights
which is still pretty green yeah but
again it's off to the races i'm the
biggest show in the world
fighting chase gormley shortly after
that i'm fighting gabriel gonzaga he's
ranked top 15 in the world
i beat him and then after that it's
marco krokop who you know
legend knock him out and i'm fighting no
garen brazil
you know it's just like what is in now
you're going to brazil
and but i realized what was going on i'm
like this is not like this needs to slow
the [ __ ] down like why what's going on
because i was a
i was a cheat code in the system like
this isn't how it should work and i i
knew it you know i knew it i was young
and even then i knew it i was like this
it's this is going to catch up to me man
it's going to catch up you always
believe that
i knew because you're going to get to a
certain point where
you're going to fight a guy who's fought
the the young lion athletic kid
and he's not scared of me and that was
gabriel i'm sorry that was uh
a big nog in brazil so what happened
there
so it's the biggest fight in my career
it's ufc 134 if i remember correctly
it's in brazil
first time they went back to brazil
stacked on the co-main event what is
that like because those
arenas over there just their stadiums
are way bigger
again it'd be like fighting michael
jordan
in chicago yeah no one no one's rooting
for me
we we all my food we had to they had to
go over with a comb because they thought
they were trying poison come on oh dude
why why are you hated that much because
you're you're fighting their legend
and i was the favorite but you're not oh
you were the favorite
take care of this okay young lion legend
let's get the legend out either costing
too much money
it's in brazil but i should [ __ ]
starch this dude and uh it's just such a
weird
how old are you 25 25 maybe now what's
he
38. this is his every bit
of yeah you know like that's why like
long in the 230
yeah i'm saying like a fighter study
it's like dog years yeah saying like
he's
old and it was such a weird thing
because
i got a call from a random brazilian
number from this guy
um broken english because hey we want to
give you i think it was like
i can't remember the exact toll but we
want to give you 60 grand cash
if you knock no gear out put on because
soccer is big out there
and they go we want you to put on his
rival team where he's from after you
knock him out put on this jersey
oh my god that sounds easy enough i'll
do that like cool and i tell my manager
he's like dude be careful because
the way that works that's brazilian
mafia man they work with these football
teams these soccer teams
you gotta be careful i'm like yeah
they're just gonna drop it off so
these two gangster brazilians come in
full suits come to my hotel room
and they get the cash out and they put
in you know you have those uh
lockers like the the safes they put
put the cash in there and they go again
in broken english it's a nightmare to
figure it out
translate they go um when you win we'll
text you the code to get your money out
if you lose we'll come get it that night
like all right cool totally knew i was
messing with gangsters whatever
just wanted the cash i was young go into
the fight get knocked out
miserably get knocked out get knocked
out what round first round
no i light him up with an uppercut he's
wobbly i'm like i'm going to starch this
[ __ ] old dude
and then he weathers the storm and then
jab jab jabs and then right hand against
the cage
and i didn't see it coming knocked me
out and then i'm like
full of tears my whole family flew to
brazil
nope your mom's home mom's like get the
[ __ ] out of here
you fighting once you guys are [ __ ]
um
yeah so i'm back in the locker room just
sad
knock on the door says two brazilian
gangsters they look at me go
sorry enter the code take their money
and then you know then the the ufc after
that was just like uh again
i wasn't born i wasn't put on this earth
to fight i'm not a violent person i'm
not aggressive person i was just a
really good athlete that
that had no other options and the ufc
was a
easy way for me to make money so i knew
i had to get out
and that's the moment you knew right
there no the fight before that i knew i
had to get out i did i fought murko crow
cop
and i knocked him out and he was a
legend and we had a back and forth fight
it's one the
you know it's always on the ufc's like
all-time great fights meaning we're
going back and forth he elbows me in the
second round with an
elbow and shatters my nose she just
shatters my face
damn i had this horrible cut and i
remember like why am i so
tired like i'm in phenomenal shape why
am i [ __ ] tired
because he shattered my nose and all the
blood was clogging i had to swallow like
[ __ ] tons of blood end up knocking i
think
at the time i don't know if it is now it
was the latest
uh knockout in heavyweight history i
knocked him out like a minute to go in
the third round
starched them i mean the horrible
knockout but we're in the back
and the commission [ __ ] is in new jersey
new york new jersey the commission
[ __ ] up and gave me his check and his
was like a million something
and the guy goes oh so i see how much
he's getting paid and he's
[ __ ] up his whole face is all
distorted stuff and
i'm like oh what am i doing that was
like my hero i just [ __ ] that guy up
they give me his trick i'm like oh [ __ ]
bonus and like oh sorry sorry and then
like
my bad give him his check i'm like okay
then they give him my check i made like
16 grand
and my face and you just [ __ ] up you
were holding a million dollar check for
yeah and that's why and he deserves it
he's the legend he paid his dues
but still and i i look i i remember
staring at him this
you know this crow they call him cro cop
croatian cop his real name's like mirko
something
and uh i just remember looking like this
is no way
humans should be behaving like i have
there has to be a better way for me to
make money yeah but i'm ranked top 10 in
the world at the time
man that's got to be a hell of a
conflict yeah
i just know that you need to do
something else and but i looked at him
and
we're both so [ __ ] up man and i looked
at him i just go there has to be a
better way man
there has to be a better way for us and
i'm crying i know there has to be a
better way
and he looks at me and goes this is life
this is life and i was like it's not
though dude
i remember thinking i'm like i'm young
it's not so i was
one foot out at that exact moment coming
off the biggest one in my life
i was out the one foot out the door and
then you go to the biggest loss of your
life
biggest loss suffered another loss after
that right after
right after well like six months after i
fight this guy but the next fight
next fight lost that fight how did you
lose that one knockout
god damn now you're in an early too
early wobbled him again while with him
just an experience man again i was the
cheat code
i don't have the experience to deal with
that type of fighters those experienced
fighters
um then i go on a winning streak i win
uh
two or three in a row and then i loot my
last fight in the ufc was 214-13
to travis brown i lose to him and i knew
going into that fight that was my last
one
because i was doing a podcast with brian
cowan the fire and the kid
you know um
for years you know and i was getting
more recognized for that
my paycheck for that was more than i was
getting for fighting and was it really
yeah
and that's what and i enjoyed that i
like
having fun talking [ __ ] with brian being
you know brian brought me into the
comedy world and like
once once i got around comics it was the
first time when i
felt in my skin like i felt like oh okay
like i don't know if you've ever seen
you have kids maybe the shark's tail
oh yeah so there's a great white in
there and he doesn't want to do great
white [ __ ]
he wants to you know paint and listen to
music and dress different
i was the great white that didn't i want
to be a dolphin
never want to be big i don't like being
big i'm super
self-conscious insecure about my size so
i just never
i didn't i just didn't fit in i just
never because those guys were like
so aggro and this this this and this and
i'm like
i don't i don't think so man so uh until
i met brian and
started playing with brian you know just
at restaurants and
on air and that it's the first time i
like like oh this is what
this is what i should be doing this is
what i love to do and then
we started doing live firing the kids
that was my first time on stage and
uh bray improv ontario improv and
um i got off stage and brown's like this
what you can do for us your life you're
meant to do this
wow and the first time i was like you're
right you're right
so when how did you officially quit ufc
you have to make an announcement or you
know not really it was just
like you know they're gonna offer you
fights kept turned down then finally i
was okay tell them stop wasting
time like i'm busy doing this so i'll
let tell them
you did actually tell them i'll let them
know when i want to fight okay but you
did actually have a fight while you were
podcasting no i had
several things really all right yeah and
at the time we were doing podcasts
before everybody's [ __ ] stepmom was
doing them so
me and brian and i'd make merch
and again i'd have much money man and uh
i told brian and hey
i've always been like creative guy i
love fashion i said let me make merch
for firing the kid
because all right i go uh so i went and
talked to this printer at the ave
off in venice right off windward circle
there
and he goes hey it's gonna be about 2
200 bucks i'm like [ __ ] 2200 bucks so
i went to brian
and brian goes i'll give you the money
for that brian gave him the money the
shirt sold out
you know in like 30 seconds and uh
i was still fighting the time because i
remember i wore that shirt said abbot
kinney fight
club i wore that against andre arlovski
um i wore that instead of taking
sponsorship money i wore my shirt
and i was like the first one to kind of
do that okay yeah
instead i remember the guys back in the
day would do write it on their
back and [ __ ] and yeah we look like you
look like nascar guys yeah so for me i
was like oh no i don't want any of that
i'm gonna wear my own [ __ ]
my manager was like you're insane dude i
was like i know but this is my [ __ ] man
and wearing that is probably gonna make
you more money than that company wants
to give you for their
[ __ ] t-shirt it didn't but it was
also like it was just like to me it was
more important
yeah i was like i've never done anything
for money i'm like the money i come
i'd rather wear this and represent me
and brian and comedy and
you know walk out to the hockey on
that'd be cool so let's talk about
comedy then your first
um introduction to comedy was podcasting
right
so when did you first do stand-up ma
would be doing the live fight in the
kids with me and brian that was
just straight you know comedy show oh
that was a stand-up show not a live
podcast no no i never agreed with live
podcasts i think it's not the
the medium for it it's a bad idea i've
never been to one where i've enjoyed it
um so i didn't want to do that brian's
like no no we're going to do a show man
i'm a performer
and he goes and at the time he didn't
want to scare me he knew i wanted to
stand up he's like dude so
the way we're going to start every show
we have we had like 12 dates booked
he goes we're going to start every show
with you just telling a story
you're going to come out on your own
you're going to tell a story for the
first 10 minutes
and then i'll come out and do our thing
together okay cool
and so i'd go out tell stories or
whatever and then
you know probably 10 shows go by wait
how did you feel about stand up
wanted to do it it's totally different
than podcasting so now you're going from
boxing to mma let's say in the same
world kind of but not the same thing at
all
so what were you more comfortable with
podcasting or stand up i was comfortable
with podcasting but i knew i was
funny because i'd make brian and rogan
laugh and they kept urging me to do
stand-up
uh because we go to dinners and rogan's
like dude you gotta tell us on stage i'm
like
i wanted to inside but i was i was too
embarrassed
and by brian going you're just gonna
tell stories i didn't put that together
that i was doing stand up so i'd go out
and do stories in front of these
crowds now granted there are crowds
so it's me they're gonna be pretty
forgiving it's not like i'm doing the
comedy store
but i'm doing these stories for eight to
ten minutes and it's going well
and then we're doing like the vic
theater in chicago the big-ass theater
and we're in the back and i told brian
go hey with my story i'm trying to think
and i kept saying story and brian goes
out so cute i go he goes you think
you're telling stories ago what he goes
you're doing stand-up bubba i still want
you to [ __ ] your pants think you're
doing open mics
like you you're doing stand-up you never
did an open mic well
i have a sense okay so i'm doing that
and then uh i was like oh [ __ ] i am
doing stand-up so i start writing put
more effort into it
and then we do a live find kid at the
commie store and the week later
uh the come store booker goes hey do you
want to do a set
because it went really well i did like a
eight minute story up there and went
really well
and it was emily or somebody i forget
who's doing that
emily a shout out to emily uh who's not
moving to texas good on you
um unlike your boy
sell out uh anyways trader anyways yeah
bad guy hashtag bad guy
uh it hashtag uh sellout anyways so
uh she goes hey do you wanna do a set in
the belly room
and i go uh oh i don't know let me let
me check with brian's schedule i don't
know what schedule is and she's like no
just you
dumbass and i was like you want me to do
a set and i was like so honored
but also terrifying she goes yeah yeah
we saw you on stage in the main room
come to us at the belly room
she goes you have material right i'm
like oh yeah didn't oh yeah no doubt
so yeah come to a set we'll give you i
forget about like six minutes
so now this is your first it's my first
that was my that was like my first set
that was six years ago in the belly room
and like a dumbass i invited you know
rogan callan dalia uh
my boys will sasso my agent tom
todd feldman everybody's in the front
row man you know and i just eat
[ __ ] you know because he did it
so that was my was it a pack room that
sold out dude
packed i eat all the dicks it didn't go
well
hey all the dicks and then okay let me
ask you were you
more embarrassed about that or getting
knocked
knocked out really but yeah get dude get
knocked out your underwear
in a steel cage in front of you and you
gotta hear about it non-stop
that's like out of it and you're like
really trying you know so it's like
with it yeah i had a whole camp
you know it's like i put everything into
that uh
both stand up i i knew it was like it
was a painting i was never gonna finish
i was like
i took a brush and did one thing it's
like i can i can finish this thing over
years didn't take years
and so i just kept working man and then
i kept getting spot spots but did they
bust your balls about eating [ __ ] oh
yeah oh yeah yeah
it's brian looked at me he was like
bubba 10 years ago 10 years
i was like you think he's like 10 years
before you get a career for
doing anything and again i was thrown
into it you know and i'm six years in
now and
you know shot a special i've offers now
shoot specials with every major network
you've heard of
it's just a different animal for me but
again
with my experience in life i've learned
it's like this has to slow down
this has to we've got to slow down let
me
work on the craft that i'm passionate
about and there's a reason why i do you
know
[ __ ] eight sets in three days in la
when it's not
north korea right now you know so so
let's go back for a sec
after this you get this momentum when do
you
first go do a real open mic that week
you did yeah i hit the ground running i
mean when i say running i mean
nobody could offer me anything i would i
would say no to i'm open mics
uh restaurants bars oh good for you you
did go out and play
it yeah see i i i think that's where
if you're a comic who has animosity
towards me because my success i don't
think you really like i'm not posted on
the ground about open mics
right yeah nobody does no but you gotta
work out that's what
yeah that's what the in-betweens are
yeah and that's where you know i've been
super fortunate we have guys like rogue
and brian like
dude you you can't just do the comedy
story or the improv you
you need to go where people don't need
to eat [ __ ] yeah yeah and i've eat [ __ ]
a ton of
times that's it i mean that's how you
get good yeah figuring it out
yeah and it's great um so how long
are you in uh when you get your like
um well you're only a couple days in
when you get your
or one show in when you get the belly
room so how long are you in before you
get your special
three years three years okay three years
and what happens
three are you nervous i mean this is
like going to brazil and fighting this
dude now in the comedy world
and i wish somebody before i got on that
flight to brazil i'm like bubba
let's uh let's let's hold off
let's just take it take it easy huh
let's take it easy you're not dave
chappelle
so but but listen i've i've known you
for a little bit not well because you
know i just don't know
yeah and you're newer to this so i
haven't gotten to know you too well but
sitting here talking to you i know
you're a good dude yeah
you've never seen in any of these
stories like you've let your ego get in
the way like oh
shoot i can so did you with con like
were you concerned when you got the
special were you worried like it might
be too early like
it's what you said you're gonna see a
pattern and i have so
are you worried that it's too early the
way it was with football the way it was
with
mma yeah because my really
so we jump forward to the special but
between that belly room show and the
special
a year after that belly room show comedy
central came to me
and uh they didn't come to me they
i heard from a mutual friend that
they're doing auditions for this is not
happening
and i love that show and ari shafir was
doing it
and uh i called arias okay i'm not
asking for any special treatment
but what stories are the best he's like
self-deprecating
fun stories funny bits or what crush is
on there
so i had this old fight story uh that
was also my special
different story but same premises more
beefy for a special
so i i made the cut on comedy central
that's not happening i think he said
like four million views or three
views tonight so that was that was like
my first big deal in comedy
that was that your first tv appearance
it was my first tv appearance it was
like when
you know that was game time that was
like you know i'm around big comics
they're going on stage i can tell
they're nervous i'm like oh [ __ ] if
they're nervous i should definitely be
nervous
that was like my first taste of like the
big leagues in comedy
and that that went really well that went
really really well for me
and that that was my big break in comedy
that
getting on this not happening economy
central and i have like this super super
soft spot in my heart for comedy central
you know and ari and eric abrams i mean
it's such a show i mean to take
but also to take that from digital to
network big time
come on it's the first one they ever did
that with big time
yeah so i think already too i got a i
did a couple
yeah yeah that was a big big deal for me
because you know for
for me get on comedy central meant
everything so
i i still you know i owe comey central
one
so that was a big deal for me man and
you know so then i'm on tour i'm
headlining all around you know
selling theaters out and headlining you
know all sorts of
big clubs and showtime you know
their comedy team saw me do a set in the
in the main room
and then that's when the talk for the
special started to happen and then
they're like yeah we have a budget for
if you want to do it and i was like
i have an hour i'm gonna get rid of it
so hold on your
tv appearances go comedy central this is
not happening
showtime special yes sir there's no
other tv appearances at all in there
nothing wow that is [ __ ] fast fast
that's really fast yeah fast and then
uh you know you get you know uh
compensated for the special and stuff
like that like have an
hour so might as well do it with them
you know i just remember
rogan and brian my guys and dalia being
like
you know i slow down man i'm like i know
but it's there
you know and they're trying to do me a
solid it's it's not that that
that special is bad i think everyone's
first special is like
you just know you can do so much better
like especially i will not everyone
watch i won't go i watch my old sets or
anything never like oh it's the worst
and hell i thought i was ready yeah you
know what i mean i'm like oh
yeah yeah yeah
yeah i know bro so there are some things
i look back on and go
god i'm glad i didn't get that right
glad i didn't get that
yeah yeah so yeah so i think for me i
look back on my coff
if i would i've i would have wrote it
this way now you just have more
experience you know
uh i'm still proud of it and that's do
you ever go back and watch it
never have you ever never never gone i i
sat in on the edit to make sure it was
done the way i wanted but
since that nothing i don't have any bits
from it nothing nothing
you do none of that material at all now
it's all burned god no
yeah no hell no i can't wait to get out
of that you know get out of it because
there's
a lot of fight reference in that i
completely get away from that now so
what now
you go from that special what happens
after the special
um you know i i think with specials
especially now you know that was
two years ago when it when it aired you
know january
was at 19. god was it yeah 2019 is when
i
went when that aired i shot in 2018 so
where'd you shoot it
uh spreckels theater in san diego okay
so i think
um as far as was it successful you know
it was one of the most viewed specials
on showtime of all time
um was it yeah wow yeah so you know
you got to get the eyeballs i sent more
tickets from it so
you know i think from a business
perspective showtime and the people
involved like dude
home run but to me i'm like i wish i
would have waited you know i wish i
would have waited but
why um just just because you know how
this is kind of you know
i know why whatever from from year to
year like
you grow so much especially me so it's
like you know if
anybody who's came to my show now
they're probably like geez you know
blown away about how much better i've
gotten
so it's just like these leaps that you
make you know
so um business-wise success me
as far as creative i wish i would have
waited all right now
football comes fast you're out mma comes
fast you're out
comedy comes fast you seem to be in no
matter what what is it about
comedy that wasn't about mma
or football uh because i think i was
this is what i should be doing i was
made to do this i
enjoy the process i enjoy riding i enjoy
going on the road i just
i love everything about it and does your
dad support this now he's told you
always use your brain so where is he at
he likes it he just i don't think he
realizes what i
to the magnitude that what i do stand up
at you know i think
when i shot my special like he he flew
out he didn't come to the taping way to
go dad
didn't come to the way to go aha mom
like you're only doing one show
no my uh my dad just doesn't
he doesn't realize that at what level
i'm working and stand up so he flies out
here after the special to see his
grandson and we're at the mall and he
said nothing and i don't it's whatever
you know
did he watch it yeah i don't think so so
then uh he looks at me goes
uh how'd your speech go speech yeah
right i was like all right man you're
just
just [ __ ] it that's funny [ __ ] it man
[ __ ] it [ __ ] it just [ __ ] it
and then he got then i do the the um
the the club in denver comedy works
big club grew up with comedy works you
know i love
and comic works is close to my heart
because
you know you know how it works in the
comedy business they'll put youtubers on
they'll put [ __ ] famous people from
real housewives orange county
celtics the comedy works
when my agent often went no we're not
booking that guy he hasn't been doing it
long enough and my agent goes okay
well he's from there so it's a he'll do
the theater the paramount across the
street if you guys don't put him in
there and i don't want to do that
i'm not trying to do that i want to be
viewed as a real comic
ask her what i can do to work that club
oh good for you she goes come into a set
so i'm flat it's windy wendy yeah so i
shot out the cavs out yeah so i came in
there and did a set
came into the set the following year
they offered me one night
thursday night did the one night and
then after that they've offered me full
weekends
all right so they have a super you know
close spot in my heart because that's
the way it should be
done well she does it right man she
doesn't
few clubs dude every [ __ ] club i say
this to her all the time
every manager every waitress waiter
bartender
server whatever should have to train in
that club before they go out into the
[ __ ] comedy world
that is the way yeah they do they do it
right they treat you like a professional
yeah you're not treated like that most
places you go
yeah you know i've been in some places
where you know
especially early on when i was
headlining i'm like who's on before me
and they're you know they're
ashy [ __ ] frank from youtube and he
i'll sit back and watch the show and
it's a [ __ ] train wreck
i'm like this isn't stand-up man he's
dancing for half the time
and he's doing [ __ ] tick tock videos
yeah i'm like you gotta fight
i don't wanna be involved with this man
that guy is a [ __ ] puppet i don't
and his homies are on stage i'm like i
don't want to be part of this man
so you you're walking a fine line in
common you are
man there's all kinds in comedy that's
the thing
comedy is where the rejects from
everywhere else
land you know what i mean like i it's so
funny when i sit down the communities
are like well i was a theater reject i'm
like
the theater threw you out you know what
i mean like that's how you know where
comedy is yeah we're all the
the bottom line yeah everyone's [ __ ]
up well brother thank you for coming on
of course
man been a really [ __ ] informative
fun episode it's weird for me nice to
get to know you this
yeah i love you man i've always been a
fan it's weird for me you're right
because i do all my
other shows it's weird for me to be on
this side yeah it's rare i get to
uh talk about myself i'm glad you did
man i appreciate you
yeah it's a weird story hopefully it's a
great one dude like
look man most people would be thrilled
to ever get to the nfl and have
you say a cup of coffee we call it a
shot of a special shot of express
yeah you can drag out a cup of coffee i
had an espresso
and they still claim me like they'll
tell you
like when the bills are doing the play
like dude hashtag build mafia once you
sports more i'm like
hey i played as many games as you did
bubba like i'm a broncos fan oh
[ __ ] but that would be enough for a lot
of people
then to get to the mma would be enough
for a lot of people
yeah but i mean it's open it's all
perspective i think it's all perspective
like i feel like a failure in football i
feel like a failure in the ufc
i feel you know comedy is different
animal
but well there's times i certainly feel
like oh there's some time i get off
stage oh my god
um yeah so it's all perspective you know
if i was a kid and you sat me down like
okay dude so you're gonna get a shot in
the nfl
uh you're gonna play division one
football and then you're gonna get the
uc when you're like top ten in the world
i'm like holy [ __ ] they're like right
and that cool
but now as an older man like ah [ __ ]
dude you know so it's just
perspective well thank you for doing the
show dude it's been a lot of fun yeah
thank you man
uh as always ryan sickler on all social
media ryan sickler.com we'll talk to you
all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you